when you get a bunch of big Hollywood
stars together there's bound to be some
tension even if their characters are
getting along on screen the actors
behind the scenes don't always see eye
to eye yeah are a few actors who just
couldn't stand working together
Dustin Hoffman and Meryl Streep Dustin
Hoffman and Meryl Streep's working
relationship on the set of the
oscar-winning film Kramer vs Kramer
played out a lot like the divorced
couple they were playing on screen over
the years the Streep has been vocal
about the intensity that Hoffman brought
to each scene which often startled her
and sometimes downright scared her
Streep told CBS news just how far
Hoffman would go on set in another scene
he slapped me and you and when I see the
movie I see the imprint of his hand on
the thing she added I think Hoffman is
very very gifted but it wasn't the most
fun I've ever had on film yeah no
kidding
James Franco and Tyrese Gibson much like
Meryl Streep Tyrese Gibson wasn't happy
with the intense physicality that
co-star James Franco brought to the set
of 2006 s Annapolis particularly when it
came to shooting the film's big boxing
match Gibson described the experience to
Elle magazine whenever would have to get
in the ring for boxing scenes and even
during practice the dude was full-on
hitting me
Franco later apologized for his behavior
telling GQ I was probably a jerk I was
not purposely cruel to him but I was
probably so wrapped in my performance
that I was not as friendly as I could
have been Charlize Theron and Tom Hardy
Charlize Theron and Tom Hardy had a
love-hate relationship on a set of
George Miller's 2015 dystopian epic Mad
Max fury road
okay made that a hate hate relationship
the oscar-winning actress put it bluntly
in an interview with Esquire saying that
she and Hardy went at it on the set
it was the isolation and the fact that
we were stuck in a reg for the entire
shoot we shot a war movie on a moving
truck there's a very little green screen
it was like a family road trip that just
never went anywhere
we never got anywhere we just drove we
drove into nothingness and that was
maddening sometimes she also added that
even though the actors drove each other
crazy
they still had an immense amount of
respect for one another how they even
left her a semi sentimental note after
it was done which read you are an
absolute nightmare
but you are also king awesome I'll kind
of miss you love Tommy Tom Hardy and
Shia LaBeouf Hardy's history of beefing
with co-stars that didn't start with
Sharon he also reportedly got in a
fistfight with Shia LaBeouf on the set
of 2012 lawless which LaBeouf apparently
won Hardy himself later admitted as much
although his description of the fight
sounded a little tongue-in-cheek he
knocked me else Parker out cold he's a
bad bad boy he is he's quite
intimidating as well he's a scary dude
he just attacked me he was drinking
moonshine for his part LaBeouf claimed
Malika had nothing to do with his
aggression toward Hardy
telling MTV that their onset battle
wasn't moonshine related at all and was
instead straight love we were playing
brothers there was a constant finger in
the ear teasing thing going on for a
while it was all love I love to do like
a brother straight-up Jennie Garth and
shannen doherty these team TV queens
were on top of the world when they
shared the screen in Beverly Hills 90210
but Jennie Garth and shannen doherty had
a very hard time getting along with each
other on the set in her 2014 tell-all
book deep thoughts from a Hollywood
blonde garth wrote i don't know why it
is but there was a universal truth when
you put three teenage girls together
some serious is going to go down there
were times when we loved each other and
there were times when we wanted to claw
each other's eyes out in 2012 shannen
doherty revealed that whatever rivalry
had developed between the pair had since
subsided telling glamour
I did the new 902 100 with Jenny and
there was something very different about
our friendship
we were able to look at each other as
grown women and really acknowledge that
we like to the other person was now as
adults but as it turns out you don't
have to be a teenage girl to want to
smack your co-star you can be a golden
one to be Arthur and Betty White Betty
White is so likable that it's hard to
imagine anyone not wanting to become her
best friend
unfortunately whites of B personality
didn't mesh well with co-star Bea Arthur
during the filming of their iconic
sitcom The Golden Girls White's revealed
during a 2013 panel discussion with the
New York Times we were all close but our
personalities are all so different be
found me a pain in the neck sometimes
because of my positive attitude I'm
happy all the time and that made be mad
sometimes
woe is me Freddie Prinze jr. and Kiefer
Sutherland Jack Bauer might have been a
fan favorite superstar of the small
screen but Kiefer Sutherland's co-star
Freddie Prinze jr. absolutely despised
the working of the actor on the set of
24 he told ABC news Keitha was the most
unprofessional dude in the world
That's not me talking trash I'll say it
to his face I think everyone that worked
with them have said that Prince's
dislike for Sutherland extended so far
that he said he even considered quitting
show business after working with him why
was Prince so bothered by Sutherland for
one a prince had to take his shoes off
to do scenes with him for the show
because he was so much taller than
Sutherland just put the guide an Apple
box or don't hire me next time you know
I'm six feet and he's five foot four
hey it could have been worse after all
this is Jack Bauer we're talking about
finish my Saturday yes
geez just take off your shoes man thanks
for watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]